think I think if I see my man treat his
mum with respect you know treat treat
his the women in his family how they
should be treated because I've seen a
lot of guys and they they're horrible to
their parents who is your last boyfriend
three years ago that my only boyfriend
okay was he nice to his mom
yeah very nice who rounded the
relationship
um me
so uh let's say they said listen to what
women do not say
but um
yeah he was nice his mum but he also
liked to do a lot of really bad things
so that didn't do it for me but that is
definitely a big thing though still the
parents um okay looking at hygiene so
you want to be nice to your mother and
shower all right hi Jean
um for me I like a man with money
gonna say it because I need to feel
stable as well you know and women like
to be looked after I appreciate the
honestyles
and I feel like thank you there's a lot
of times where how much
give me a number a lot so I've been
single for quite a while now and I feel
like I'm looking after myself all the
time it gets to a point you get fed up
with that and you actually just want a
nice masculine man to take care of you
and put you in these arms I like that
and everyone's different but that's
what's show me a number how much does he
have to make
how much
as long as I've got a nice house I've
got a nice car what is what does a nice
house go for in London oh I wouldn't
live in England anyway I'd live abroad
definitely oh so you're looking for a
man in another country no they would
want to move so hopefully he's got his
businesses all settled and we can go
what makes you think that guy will
choose you an interesting question you
know what I might never get a rich man
in my life but that's what I like so
hopefully it get there but okay I might
never get there I'm taking steps to get
there at the moment I'm healing on
myself I've got a lot of issues I need
to sort out before I can ever get a
partner okay and that's how are you
healing them therapy oh okay yeah I
think therapy makes you crazier no you
know what I think all the women I know
that go to therapy get worse yeah and I
can actually agree with that but the
only reason I'm getting this therapy
because it's free at the moment and I do
actually need some sort of help so is it
a male or a female it's a female I'm
gonna just you should go to a male
therapist really yeah women shouldn't be
therapist that's just my opinion I mean
I'm in the psychology program at the
school I promise you these women that
are giving you they're horrible yeah
horrible they're insane men look to
solve problems so a guy's going to tell
you if I have this problem so that you
solve it women are just gonna say oh
it's okay tell me about your trauma well
so I have had a men therapist that have
made me feel really uncomfortable and
flirt with me and that didn't solve any
of my problems well I felt uncomfortable
at my therapy session so to me I'll feel
more comfortable with a woman I had a
more natural how do you flirt
just making comments what's your social
media and things like that you know
making me feel uncomfortable because
everyone he knew that I'm a essay no SW
and SWS a sex worker say that right W
yeah do you think that helps or hurts
with your mental health yeah that's it
so so much okay I'll be so real what can
you why do you keep doing it then
because at that moment I mean like a bit
of a loophole where it's a bit hard to
come out of it where I'm just used to
money being thrown at me I'm scared to
go back into a normal job routine how
how much in savings do you have savings
um
do I really have to answer that do you
have more than like okay what do you
what do you roughly make a year yeah I'd
say maybe not on our Earth but all
together maybe I'd say about 50k 50k
yeah for you that's sex work yeah you
said you think you're worth 50k a year
no but I don't work a lot though with it
I do you know I don't overdo it because
when I was a bit younger I overworked
and that's when I was doing a really
black bad place I overdid it so I've
taken a bit of a step back I don't even
do my only only fans anymore
um I'm gonna do like Dominatrix and come
in and that just keeps me Steady for now
yeah well I'm just thinking if you want
to get out oh no of course of course
right so like like it might help to get
some savings so then yeah yeah I've got
savings I've got saved don't get me
wrong I've got savings but also I've
gotten a lot of debt as well and I also
had to go for a court case so I'm
spending money on solicitors you know
things happen in life life is one big
journey and I feel like everyone's
journey is different some people have
really good life and some people don't
have a good life so what made you get
into that
well um the sex work sort of thing
um I used to work in a care home and I
was actually very like depressed very
low and I wasn't making a lot of money
and I had my ex-boyfriend at the time
that used to
he used to really make me feel low you
know and even like we'd go out for meals
and he'd say have you got the 10 pound
from the mill we used to always make me
split and I used to think to myself like
like I care for you I love you I treat
you try and treat you well and you never
gave me that back and then I worked in
the care home and I was sitting there
one day and I thought I can't do this
anymore my mind don't even want to help
like help
um
and then I'll sit in there and speaking
to one of the old guys I used to look
after in the care home and I told him my
whole plan about starting the only fans
you know and he sat there and he said to
me do it why are you not doing it you're
going to be old like me one day sitting
in a chair you're gonna like die
basically one day just do it and I've
always wanted to subscribe yeah you know
what but he didn't make it till that
time because he passed away a few months
after but I started it and um I was 19
2019 you're working in a care hospital
you sorry it's harder it gets very hot
question how many years did you run your
only fans
um
probably about a year and a half then I
stopped
yeah so I was working in the care home
and then I started it and I knew that if
I started the obf my ex would leave me
alone because he hated things like that
and I knew that he'd really leave me
alone because we were so toxic together
and then I was I was in work I checked
my phone I think I made maybe like 2K in
that day and to me that's a lot I
haven't come from a big family I haven't
come from a stable family at all I think
2K in a day as well and for me it was
because I was getting 400 pound a week
from their care home and I was working
12-hour shifts and five days a week so
to me that was amazing and how did you
see you are now I'm 22 now okay so
you've been doing it for like three
years yeah and then um I said to my
manager I'll need to leave work like I
don't really want to be here and I told
him my situation was the only phone she
said to me just go so I went and I just
never looked back so why did you pick
that route instead of like I don't know
marrying rich
girl you were 19. thank you you were
with the guy for three years so you
couldn't have been uh I mean well you
probably weren't streeting that much so
if you're with a guy for three years
were you maybe you were okay yeah I was
a mess I was a mess I had no control
over my emotions I felt like I didn't
even know who I was right I feel like
when you're in a young relationship you
don't even know who you are as a person
at that point you grow to learn who you
are why ruin your own life you could
have got married ruin someone else's too
I don't want to get married I'm against
marriage I don't ever want to get
married thank you
I just think it's like a shame because
there's a way to utilize female Beauty
in a different way and still get the
outcomes that yeah you know what I mean
like now now you're in a position where
it's gonna be tough to ever be with a
guy long term yeah but maybe I don't
want to be of a guy long term maybe I
want to live with free cats at my home
with all my cactuses what do you want
your life to look like at 65. I'll
probably be dead by then so I don't know
I don't think that far ahead because
laugh
yeah it probably will but if it does it
does I don't really care yeah you do no
I don't I think you feel a bit under
yeah
then life hits you and
maybe it will hit me but it's not
hitting me up and I'm here I'm healthy
you know I'm living I've got good family
members like you still get it like I
don't think women like we realize how
much we like need attention from men
yeah like we need like we need I agree
with that and so like right now you're
still young you're still attractive
you're still gonna get attention from
men but like at 40 to 50 people women
become basically invisible yeah I know
that does scare me actually I thought
about that so if you don't if you don't
get a husband before then like what does
life look like your parents will pass
away at some point your your siblings
will have their own families like if you
don't start thinking long term like what
does your life look like and I don't say
this to be mean
you're in the position you're in already
you can't do anything to like yeah yeah
to change it yeah but it's like you know
if you want to be in a position where
you're happier like wouldn't it make
sense to maybe start put that away
maybe but um I don't know I feel like
there's so much in my life that I'm
trying to sort out first like my mental
health and my family issues and a lot of
my childhood trauma that I still have to
deal with daily so I'm trying to sort
that up first because I feel like I
can't think straight at the moment with
my head it's just like one big tornado
so it's so trauma like what do you mean
you need to go through like because I
never understand when people say
childhood trauma okay when I was younger
I was essayed and um it was my mum's
boyfriend so
like that was quite intense you know
I'm not getting upset it's just a bit
you know
um yeah so how long have you been going
to therapy for it
um I was going when I was 16 for a year
and then I stopped before I didn't need
it anymore and then I've only been going
for about five months now well because
it's just like the
the sad thing about the therapy is it
just seems like they just kind of making
money off of their patients instead of
like trying to get you guys out and I
think a lot of times that's like women
doing it you know I know maybe you had
the bad experience with the guy but it
might make sense to try to find a
different yeah I guess so you know that
just because like what what does your
future look like you have to figure out
how to move on yeah yeah definitely
yeah okay
and sometimes there are things that you
can't actually get over so looking at it
endlessly you makes you live in the
moment yeah I always feel like I'm I
wake up and I'm still living in the past
still like my head just keeps living in
the past you know and I've just found
that if I focus more on the future you
don't live as much in the past yeah you
know but like right now you're not even
thinking like long term yeah also if you
had a partner one that was good for you
not just any old partner if you were
focused on them yeah and they're focused
on you then you also wouldn't have to I
feel like that is why I do hate my job
because I don't glamorize sex work at
all I think don't start it it does ruin
your life it ruins your mentality and it
ruins how you view men and how men
should view you so yeah if I could sit
here and regret doing sex work I
probably would regret it only because
the stuff I put on the internet as well
because that's not me that's just what
I've done for money and you shouldn't
have to do them things for money to you
know you're losing your not morals but
it can have been private yeah it could
have been private and I feel like where
I was a bit younger and I was getting
too excited because of the money I had
no parents to guide me I kind of lost
the control and now I'm in this
situation
but um yeah I'm just thinking there's
like steps you could take to get out of
it because you know it's like you can
you're able to make savings put it away
yeah yeah learn like a skit because I'm
just thinking like you're you're a
pretty girl there's ways to monetize
your beauty in a different way yeah
start a YouTube channel yeah reaction
yeah right you could do you could do
um sales yeah I don't
would sales people 100 sex work sex
workers that's what's interesting to me
and this is actually something like I
said when I was dating a gal that turned
out to be a stripper in like a really
popular one apparently
um what really interested me in her
psychology she was probably the best
person I've ever met at just reading men
and just understand like I don't believe
that anybody really knows human nature
like sex workers do that's so they
really like these girls learn things
yeah she can look she can look at a guy
and I guarantee it I've met you like two
minutes ago we were going to show it's
like she can look at a guy and
immediately know how much money he has
would he cheat on his wife and how
quickly and like and she knows she would
you know you don't remember yeah of
course because the gal I was with she
was like she would look at that she's
like I'm like oh that guy's my friend he
was married she's like oh he would cheat
on his wife and a minute I'm like really
and she would just know she's like I
know the look I know I know the feel I
know the energy like they just
understand that so yes it definitely is
good for sales but coming I know that
you did not like sales and that's fine I
loved sales I'll tell you no no no I
don't mind sales I hate selling copiers
yes we had a guy in our cup we had a guy
in our company that's like one of our
top sales people he used to sell copiers
came to us he likes his life now but
there is something um two sales that I
think is really really important tying
into this
um how you feel and like all the
emotional stuff I mean obviously like
that's that's a battle you have to you
have to you have to fight that's a
battle you have to win it is what it is
everybody has some trauma not at the
same level you know we're different but
everybody comes everybody's family is
left up in some way or another like it's
just the fact we all are you know and
one thing I'm really glad about like
when I was 20 years old and I felt like
I was a victim of the world
and I think a lot of people you know at
a young age feel like they're victims
like no I'm not the best looking no I'm
not the smartest no I'm not this the
that I don't have a big brother to teach
me things before I was 20 the internet
wasn't like a huge thing which is kind
of crazy so we didn't have these
podcasts to learn about life which is
why I appreciate what Pearl does so much
because you know we get to learn about
life
I was really really lucky to to take a
sales position where people probably
cared about the money I was making them
more than they cared about me but at
least the steps that I needed to take to
build myself included a significant
amount of discipline a significant
amount of accountability and being
honest with myself because I didn't get
paid if I didn't sell anything so so I
was had to be very brutally honest with
myself and extremely disciplined but
what really helped was getting around
another group of people around me that
were disciplined and growing and they
didn't resent My Success they celebrated
my success and I celebrated their
success and when I failed they didn't
crap on me they said hey you failed
let's work together to make you better
if you want to be better you know and so
one of the things actually we do in our
company is and I think Tate and those
guys have the War Room people the worm
was I think that's brilliant I think
just giving men men a place to meet
other ambitious successful or striving
men in school yeah and that's we need
that we do the same thing in our company
like we bring guys in and we literally
mold them and work with them to make
them more accountable to grow and just
some guys resent it yes they leave and
they resented because they don't like to
be in an environment where they feel
like they're not enough but other guys
flourish in that environment and as a
man I'm talking from a man's perspective
you don't have like a woman can cry and
still move into another man's life a
couple years later men don't have that
option like we need to be building all
the time and if you feel like you're a
dude and you're a little bit victimized
it's time to step up and and get around
people that will help you grow I agree
with that definitely works I'm just
thinking for you you've been doing of
for three years like that's three years
you can still get out you can still get
I haven't actually been doing it for
free I've been I did it for like really
I was on on it for like a year and a
half and then the other two years I had
it but I never put any effort into it
that what I'm saying is right now it's
still you can sell out you can semi get
it off oh no 100 I'd never want to be a
sex work the rest of my life away the
way the way you're on track like that's
what you're on track to do if you don't
make life changes quick well no I
haven't been though I have been yeah
changes have you been making I've I've
made a limited company I'll start with a
cleaning company I just need to make my
website at the moment so I've got the
cleaners for it like not the cleans I've
got the um
what's it called why does my mind my
mind go I'm like you should get the oaf
girls
you know you know you know you know Mr
Miyagi wiped the window she's like
my plan so my plan was to start a legit
one first year I've got um a friend who
does an Airbnb business so I thought I
couldn't use the cleaners for that to
start with and then my Twitter page and
get the new emails in you know what I
mean the sugar does have the nice houses
okay that's actually that's amazing and
remember one time I was on your show a
while ago and and the story was like
um I told my wife we should get a
cleaner because we have four kids and
like a very large house with a lot of
toys and stuff and she's like okay fine
I'll try it and then the cleaner came
and it was this like young Ukrainian
girl and she cleaned the house
spotlessly and she was good looking and
my wife's like I'm never inviting the
cleaner I will clean so women watching
this not just the men the women should
be you know if you're a guy and your
wife's not cleaning hire this lady in
her company your wife will be a cleaner
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible